und über diese krawalle möchte ich jetzt
auch mit unserem bild chefreporter frank
schneider sprechen
frank wir haben auch immer wieder
gelesen und gehört dass auch hooligans
an diesen krawallen beteiligt gewesen
sein sollen jetzt gelten ja die
hooligans in holland besonders als
gefährlich warum die hooligans in
rümlang gelten als sehr brutal sehr
organisiert und treffen sich auch immer
wieder zu so genannten dritt
auseinandersetzungen das sind dann eben
die übrigens die sich außerhalb des
stadions außerhalb von fußballspielen
treffen
sie haben da eine klare struktur treffen
sich zu klein und deshalb nutzen sie
jetzt außerhalb der sozusagen die
zuschauer freien zeit in den ligen auch
offenbar diese events um sich zu treffen
zu krümeln polizisten anzugreifen man
muss dazu allerdings auch sagen die
hooligans haben seit der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 nicht nur in
holland auch in deutschland gab es ja
diese bewegung massiv eine sogenannte
organisation gebildet
juli ins damals gegen salafisten rogesa
abgekürzt und damals 20 16 gab es
schwere ausschreitungen in köln 20 17
auch noch mal wo plötzlich über 5000
hooligans muss sich auch überlegen die
sich sonst wirklich bis aufs blut
bekämpfen im wahrsten sinne des wortes
plötzlich gemeinsam unterwegs waren die
uni genannten das in den farben getrennt
in der sache der 1
und meinten sie müssten die sozusagen
erheben um staatliche probleme in
angriff zu nehmen weil sie sich eben als
große macht verstehen mit großem
marktpotenzial
dann hat sich das etwas beruhigt und
jetzt ist seit geraumer zeit in
deutschland aber auch in anderen ländern
so dass die hooligans eben diese corona
leuten doch verschwörungstheoretiker dem
uns unterwandern
wir hatten ja jüngst bei den schweren
ausschreitungen in leipzig teilweise
eben auch in berlin immer wieder
hooligans dabei es gibt auch vier
kleinere organisationen in nordrhein
westfalen dann gibt es die sogenannte
deutsche bruderschaft wird sich daneben
liegen verschiedener vereine sozusagen
zusammenschließen und dann immer sehr
martialisch bei diesen demonstrationen
aufgetreten sind ziemlich aggressiv
gegenüber polizei vorgehen
und da scheint jetzt in holland
sozusagen auch mit der ausbildung zu
sein für diese massive gewalt und die
hooligans in deutschland zum teil
publikum natürlich alle nach holland es
gab auch gestern hinweise der
bundespolizei dass einige uhlig ins aus
deutschland auch eben weil angereist
sind um dort mitzumachen
und dieser ist natürlich jetzt dass
diese bewegung auch wieder nach
deutschland start möglicherweise hier
auch genauso aus
und frank angesichts die bilder die wir
dort sehen
glaubst du das würde zu sagen hat die
politik oder auch die polizei dort
versagt oder war mit solchen
ausschreitungen gar nicht zu rechnen
ja das ist hier hat die politik versagt
es natürlich immer die frage wenn man
solche bilder sieht die polizei versagt
weil das einsatzkonzept man muss
natürlich eins hier sagen erstmals
natürlich ein politisches problem genau
wie bei uns ja auch dass die wie soll
ich sagen die toleranz und das
verständnis der menschen immer weiter
abnimmt insbesondere zwei neben gut die
großen krise herrscht man das gefühl hat
man kommt nicht vom fleck jetzt kommen
die mutation wann hat er das gefühl
spätestens wenn überhaupt im sommer
werden wir geimpft und das ist ein
großes problem deswegen ist natürlich
die allgemeine akzeptanz der bevölkerung
nicht mehr so groß in bestimmten gruppen
noch viel weniger
das entlädt sich dort das ist sicherlich
das politische problem das lässt sich
aber auch nicht klären im moment es wird
sich nichts verändern es gibt momentan
keinen impfstoff das heißt die
unzufriedenheit wird beibehalten bleiben
dazu kommt dann sicherlich noch und das
ist auch ein punkt dass die polizei sich
natürlich fragen lassen muss warum
kriegt sie das nicht unter kontrolle
aber da muss man auch dieser weise sagen
die frage ist wie man muss überlegen die
polizei wird an verschiedensten stellen
an genau das ist ja nicht wie sonst bei
einer demonstration ich weiß es gibt
demonstrationen die sind geplant diesen
möglicherweise sogar angemeldet ich weiß
ungefähr wo sie sich treffen was die
vorhaben das ist ja hier überhaupt nicht
so die menschen kommen haben sie aus
ihren häusern in kleinen gruppen und
plötzlich zum einbruch der dunkelheit
oder später um 21 uhr wenn die
ausgangssperre beginnt beginnen diese
ausschreitungen und das ist ja völlig
dezentrales wird mal da angegriffen
hatte adam rennen die gruppen weiter
sind teilweise überhaupt nur von zehn
leuten teilweise auch gruppe von 50
leuten und da wird angegriffen wieder
weggerannt
das heißt die polizei kommt gefühlt
immer zu spät und teilweise verstehen
die leute sich auch in ihren häusern die
wohnen ja dass man sich auch vor ständig
gegen der da teilweise aus wo sie wohnen
verstehen dann wiederum häusern und die
form der plünderung muss man natürlich
auch noch sagen wenn es von kronzeugen
den übrigens ausgegangen ist man hat
gestern abend auch deutlich gesehen dass
ich jetzt auch junge frustrierte
jugendliche offenbar darunter mischen
insbesondere auch mit
migrationshintergrund wir kennen das ja
auch unser stuttgart und anderen städten
wo es eben die sogenannte party und
eventszene dann ja mit massiven
ausschreitungen und die hooligans
distanzieren sich zum beispiel von
diesem plünderung absolut und wenn man
die videos und internet sich an
schaut bei diesen plünderungen sieht man
auch wirklich nicht diese kollegen
strukturen
das sind mehr aus den vorstädten junge
männer mit migrationshintergrund häufig
die dann eben dort sozusagen jetzt auch
mitmachen und das ist natürlich nicht
die menge lage die für die polizei das
ganze noch viel schwieriger
komplizierter und eben auch gefährlicher
macht und da hat die polizei in
deutschland natürlich auch ein ganz
starkes auge drauf weil das kann ein
flächenbrand werden der sich auch auf
deutschland ausweiten dass man natürlich
um jeden preis vermeiden denn noch mal
wo will die polizei aktivieren sie weiß
ja überhaupt nicht wo passiert wollte
was in welcher stadt an welcher stelle
sie rennt also mehr oder weniger immer
hinterher die täter verschwinden schnell
wieder an anderer stelle geht es wieder
los
also ich befürchte da werden wir noch
viele unruhige nächte in holland und
möglicherweise irgendwann auch in
deutschland erleben
das heißt würdest du sagen dass die
polizei hilflos ist was kann sie denn
machen um jetzt diese randalierer zu
stoppen wenn du mir sagst dass man gar
nicht weiß wo solche angriffe dann
stattfinden und völlig dezentral
stattfinden
ja das ist natürlich die massivität
immer muss sagen die polizei mit aller
macht da rein geht aber wir erinnern uns
alle an den gipfel g20 in hamburg er war
alle polizei aus deutschland die
überhaupt verfügbarer war in hamburg ist
begrenzt auf eine stadt seien ungefähr
5000 randalierer und die haben ja
gesehen was da passiert ist
da gab es ja auch stunden völlig außer
kontrolle in der schanze es heißt alle
polizisten aus deutschland verfügbare
und waren in hamburg ist waren 5000
lehrer kaum in den griff zu
jetzt ist es so ist dezentral
angegriffen dann möglichst vielen
städten an vielen orten mal in der
straße mal im vorort man im zentrum und
so viel polizei gibt es natürlich nicht
die polizei versucht natürlich dich
überall möglichst in gruppen
aufzustellen um schnell an jedem ort zu
sein
aber so viel polizei gibt es daneben
auch nicht und das nutzen diese
randalierer aus und wenn man dann noch
verschiedene strukturen haben einmal
verschwörungstheoretiker corona leugner
wutbürger sage ich mal dann die
hooligans die natürlich sehr organisiert
sind auch sehr martialisch der
gewaltbereit sind man muss ja immer
wissen
eine gruppe von 20 hooligans da waren
fast 100 schafft um die in den griff zu
kriegen weil die wehren sich eben die
sind brutal die sind stark die sind
trainiert die machen kampfsport das ist
ja auch nicht mal so eben für die
polizei in griff zu bekommen und dann
jetzt noch junge strukturen junger
männer mit migrationshintergrund jetzt
auch noch mitmachen und sagen jetzt
gehen der plunder nicht sommers in apple
shop einmal umsonst ein ipad das ist
natürlich jetzt eine entwicklung ich
sehe momentan
zu problemen für die polizei in holland
und wie gesagt das ist die ganz große
sorge auch hier in deutschland wenn sich
das hieraus leitet würden wir ähnliche
probleme bekommen denn das ist einfach
schlecht sondern waren extrem schlecht
in den griff zu bekommen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren